- You know, we didn't want anyone
to go home empty handed tonight,
because we think that you are all winners,
even though you are not.
(audience laughs)
- So we got some consolation prizes,
'cause this gonna make
you feel better, right?
It's gonna make everybody feel better.
- Absolutely.
- Okay.
- Now here's something.
- What's that?
- I have a movie for somebody special.
And no one has ever seen this movie.
- Never been seen?
- It's a never been seen movie.
- Okay.
Not even by the director.
- Uh-oh.
- Now, I got a screener
of "The Last Duel".
(audience laughs)
- Never been seen.
- Okay.
Okay.
- Nobody want it, I'll hold on.
- Okay, you'll hold on that one.
Okay, you know what?
Okay, you like democracy, right?
You like democracy.
Well, here is a voter registration form
for the state of Texas.
Oh boy, kook at that.
- Oh, not again.
- They come pre-shredded now,
look at that, look at that.
There you go, you take that, there you go.
Let me see, Javier, you
heard of NFTs, right?
- Yeah.
- Guess what?
- Yeah?
- We're just going with the FTS.
This is a fudgeable token.
- Oh yeah.
- All right, so you enjoy that.
- That's gonna be worth a lot.
- Uh-huh.
- Now...
- What you got?
- There she is.
- Uh-huh.
- Dame Judy Dench.
- Don't we got something for you.
- Yes, yes.
- Now, you know what?
We got an inspirational quote for you.
- [Wanda] 'Cause you didn't win tonight.
- That's right, that's right.
And this a quote from Kim
Kardashian, "Work harder."
- That's right.
- That's what we need you to do.
- You gotta...
(audience laughs)
You gotta move that ass, Dame.
- That's right.
- You gotta move that ass.
- You gotta move it.
(audience laughs)
You gotta move it.